hey 42 here if you've ever been blamed
for something you didn't do you'll know
the Deep sense of offense that comes
with a false accusation not that time
Jeanette and accounts accused you of
nicking her Bakewell tart I mean real
stuff that could endanger your
reputation or even your freedom how
would you feel if someone painted you as
a thief abuser murderer or a witch
okay so you probably wouldn't be that
bothered by such an accusation these
days but the world was a very different
place 300 years ago back then long
before JK Rowling came along to make
which is great again witchcraft was a
grave issue get accused of Witchcraft
and you'd probably end up dead
in a minute I'll introduce you to the
man who took it upon himself to rid the
world of this terrible and completely
made up Scourge but first let's travel
back to 1692 Salem Massachusetts in this
Northeastern American village a fervent
Puritan Community resided though
God-fearing it was far from stable
plagued by ongoing feuds like the one
between the Putnam and Porter families a
dispute so divisive sailor mites were
known to break out into brawls just from
talking about it it was like an eternal
episode of Jeremy Kyle but in February
of that year an all-out War erupted and
it all started at holy man's house
one night Reverend Samuel paris's
daughter did her best impression of The
Exorcist screaming and convulsing now
from your 21st century perspective
you're probably correctly assuming that
the young lady had a serious medical
condition
but the good folks of Salem hadn't seen
all 19 series of Gray's Anatomy so their
medical knowledge was lacking thus they
came to a rather different conclusion it
must be the work of witches words spread
faster than the plague and before you
could say Avada Kedavra accusations were
flying left and right neighbors turned
on neighbors friends accused friends and
hysteria gripped the populace it was
like an episode of Love island with
slightly more demonic possession
some people claimed they saw witches
flying through the night sky on brooms
others were convinced secret meetings
were taking place in the woods during
which the local witches had a good
gossip comparing knitting patterns and
making packs of the devil whilst bathing
in the blood of children
people became incredibly suspicious of
one another and the local black cats
unexpectedly began to experience extreme
racism wherever they went
[Music]
to Ben now I love the great country of
Italy and I'd love to be able to
converse better with the locals so I'm
using Babel to learn to speak Italian
being able to speak the native language
when traveling is like having a secret
pass to unlocking extra experiences and
memories and Babel is one of the top
language learning apps in the world its
intuitive lessons help you learn a
language through real world
conversations about travel business
relationships and much more unlike other
apps that use algorithms to generate
lessons Babble lessons are created by
real people who have vast experience
with teaching languages after just a
couple of hours using Babel I learned
and can recall a long list of Italian
phrases that will be super useful in my
travels because Babel prepares you for
situations you will actually encounter
in real life oh and I especially love
its speech recognition feature you can
speak to it like a real person and it
checks if your pronunciation is on point
or a little off Babel offers live
classes too with two free classes
included in subscription and there's a
20-day money-back guarantee so you've
got nothing to lose click the link below
to get 60 off on your subscription and
leave a comment to let me know which
language you'd like to learn and a big
thanks to Babel for sponsoring this
video
one of the first girls claiming
possession was from the Putnam family
and surprise surprise the first person
she accused of being a witch came from
the Rival Paris family
things quickly spiraled out of control
and the local Judiciary were forced to
get involved the infamous Salem Witch
Trials had begun
courtrooms became the main stage of a
kind of witch-hunting circus with
dramatic testimonies outrageous
accusations and more finger-pointing
than the office kitchen after Jeanette
realized her Bakewell tart was missing
luckily for the accused there were some
reliable scientific techniques for
proving which witch was real and which
witch wasn't just kidding the methods
were all mental one well-worn
favorite was witch swimming in which the
accused was tossed into a nearby body of
water if she floated she was a witch and
would likely be executed if she sank
like a stone she was innocent
no doubt that was a huge relief for the
final few seconds of her life before
water filled her lungs and she died
another bizarre tool against witchcraft
was a baked good called a witch cake the
recipe was simple take some rye meal mix
it with Ash and a dash of the secret
ingredient urine from someone who's been
possessed by a witch Not only was this
Bake Off worthy concoction absolutely
delicious if you happen to enjoy the
taste of piss it was also a supernatural
tracking device feed it to a dog and it
would lead you straight to the witch
genius
by the time the mass hysteria in Salem
subsided more than 200 people have been
tried and 19 Innocents had been tortured
into making false confessions before
being put to death
sure the Salem Witch Trials were the
most infamous in history but many people
don't realize they were just a drop in a
sea of sorcery between the 15th and 19th
centuries as many as 60 000 people in
Europe 80 of them women may have been
killed on suspicion of being witches the
thus
8571 Quidditch teams what amidst these
horrific campaigns of torture and
persecution one man's malevolent
influence stands out Head and Shoulders
Above the Rest Matthew Hopkins was born
in Suffolk England in 1620. the son of a
Puritan vicar lets Liz known about his
life until 1644 when he shows up in
public records after moving to the town
of Manning Tree in Essex and it was
there he began a lucrative career as a
witch hunter claiming he'd been granted
a special Title by Parliament which he
hadn't nonetheless he began calling
himself the witchfinder General in
contemporary parlance that roughly
translates to Psychopathic tit
what you may ask qualifies someone to be
a tit finder General I mean witchfinder
General good interpersonnel skills a PhD
from Hogwarts actually nothing really
just the ability to convince large
numbers of people that they have
dangerous witches hiding amongst them
and that you're the man to expose them
for a fee of course
thanks to a significant social upheaval
at the time and a bizarre mix of
opposing political and religious Trends
Hopkins really didn't have to work that
hard to convince people that witches
were a very real danger that needed to
be eradicated post haste the 1640s saw
the outbreak of the English Civil War a
conflict between the royalists
supporters of King Charles the first and
the parliamentarians LED primarily by
Oliver Cromwell
as you may have guessed the royalists
supported the monarchy and the
parliamentarians wanted to limit the
king's power and establish a new
parliamentary system but religious
differences were also a huge factor most
of the parliamentarians were Puritans
if all the faiths and religions of the
world went out for lunch the Puritans of
17th century England will be the ones at
the end going through the bill
meticulously with a calculator making
sure they didn't pay a cent more than
necessary for their two glasses of tap
water and four dry crackers because they
were on a mission to purify the Church
of England from anything that smelt
remotely of Catholicism they hated their
fancy rituals and wanted to strip
everything down to the raw Basics No
Frills no decorations just straight up
hard Bible reading and prayer and when
it came to politics they weren't the
biggest fans of the king's divine right
to rule or his extravagant lifestyle so
they naturally aligned with the
parliamentarians in wanting to limit
Charles's power the Puritans are all
about being morally upright and
following God's Commandments in a
society based on strict beliefs where
fun was practically a sin they even went
on to ban Christmas and mince pies
because they were too frivolous
so you can only imagine what a force of
Witchcraft despite these two sides
wanting to kill the crap out of each
other Charles the first was completely
on board with the Puritans whole
anti-witch agenda 50 years earlier
Charles's father James the first had
penned a bestseller called demonology
detailing The Perils of magic and
Witchcraft including the recommended
punishment death
[Music]
so what exactly made someone a suspect
well not much really
simply being a bit different and by
different I mean female or one may
simply behave a bit strangely like
putting butter on your toast after the
jam
once labeled as a potential witch
titkins I mean Hopkins the witchfinder
general employed a range of foolproof
tests to determine guilt
one of his favorites was stripping and
shaving the poor suspect to search her
body for so-called witch's marks these
marks supposedly proved that the person
had made a pact with the devil and they
could be pretty much anything from
birthmarks Beauty spots moles to fur
nipples or a tattoo that reads I as a
witch
according to those in the know witch's
marks didn't bleed when pricked so if
accuses like Hopkins were unable to find
any marks on the suspect's body they
Simply Hired witch prickers men who
pricked the person all over with blunt
needles until they found a spot that
didn't bleed
ah and what do you know a witch
with the instability of the Civil War
much of England in the mid-1640s was
virtually Lawless people were afraid and
looking for scapegoats and Hopkins
willingly obliged
Hopkins and his accomplice John Stern
traveled from town to town promising to
ferret out the local witches and bring
them to justice they focused on East
Anglia where Puritan beliefs and support
for the parliamentarians was the
strongest and business was good
despite any genuine puritanical beliefs
Hopkins may have held about witches
there's little doubt he was in it for
the money his going rate was 20
Shillings a town but some places paid up
to 23 pounds about four grand in today's
money
in Ipswich a new town tax was created
just to afford Hopkin and Stern's rates
for what basically amounted to Mass
femicide
after 14 months fabricating accusations
and condemning innocent victims to The
Gallows it's estimated the witchfinder
general and his accomplice were
responsible for the deaths of up to 300
women
finally though in 1647 a well-known
Puritan preacher by the name of John
Gaul figured out what they were up to
and published a book exposing Hopkin and
Stern's dodgy techniques they retired
later that year and Hopkins died shortly
afterwards probably from tuberculosis a
legend still exists that he drowned
after being accused of being a witch and
was submitted to a bit of swimming of
his own but sadly for anyone who's into
Divine Justice it's just simply not true
in 1716 the last person was executed for
witchcraft in England but witch hunting
is a practice that continues to this day
across the world especially in parts of
Africa India Papua New Guinea and the
Amazon basin
so take my advice if you ever headed
that way cover up that extra nipple
thanks for watching